people love dressing up for Halloween
and now it has even spilled over to
animals yeah you see this all the time
on the web people are putting their pets
in costumes we're not just talking about
dogs as a service to you
I thought we'd look at some of the more
popular pet outfits right now by showing
you some Halloween costumes for pets
wouldn't you like to see first up it's a
big year for politics so here's a dog
dressed as Bernie Sanders I think this
is a great costume
[Applause]
he's got the hair down go Bernie
we didn't have the Bernie Sanders kind
of filled in it
check out this pet costume it's ripped
from the headlines a rabbit playing a
Volkswagen executive
[Applause]
right
okay can we bump dr. Phil and just talk
to him yeah we'll talk to him check out
this one it's an owl dressed as a minion
I think that's a cute idea
[Applause]
next I think this is cute it's a turtle
dressed as a staples easy button I think
that's a really cute idea that was easy
and I'm a turtle
next up based on the blockbuster movie
it's a guinea pig dressed as Chris Pratt
in Jurassic world that's just a killer
costume
[Applause]
and finally here's a great costume it's
my favorite it's for your Bulldog he can
go out as New York's famous Pizza rat
check this out
[Applause]
go
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]